i just wanted to share a quick game
from today and it was literally pretty
quick
it was played between magnus carlson
so that was the sound in the ceiling
i don't have upstairs neighbors
i don't know what that was anyway
today uh magnus carlson played
dingleran in a really really cool
london opening game it was technically a
miniature
and not only did it feature the london
but it featured like a really cool
novelty gambit from early on
so let's jump into it magnus with white
played
uh played the kind of typical starting
london moves
and um this was the second game that
they played in their their mini match
after bishop f4 c5 e3 e6
and now c3 so i think there's a lot of
people out there
even like beginner players that if they
play the london opening they could very
easily
play exactly these moves and basically
get to the same position
now ding here played one of the most
topical moves
basically the main line bishop d6
challenging the bishop on f4
and from this position white does have a
few options
i've taught this many times to beginners
and and to students
and in various lectures and i usually
recommend bishop g3 here
which i think is a simplest move where
white leaves the tension between the
bishops
and if ever bishop takes g3 you can take
back with h pawn
and enjoy the half open h file
in this position rather than using a
tempo
to retreat the bishop magnus just left
the bishop
on f4 and continued development with
knight's bd2
and this is actually a more kind of
trendy way of playing
and this idea can be used in similar
positions
where white accepts double f pawns
but then has very good control over e5
that pawn on f4 it looks weak but if
ever
like queen here or here at the very
least white has g3
if not 95. so this structure
is uh is quite pleasant for white where
um
white has a good bishop black's a little
bit passive with the bishop stuck
on on c8 so
ding left the tension between the
bishops
and took on d4 and this move exploits
the fact
that white can't take back with e pawn
of course because the bishop would hang
on f4
so it looks really obvious here to take
with a c
pawn though this would kind of leave
things very
symmetrical so in this position
carlson actually came up with a novelty
i looked this up in the mega database
and the move that magnus played
has never been seen before at least in
high rated over the board play
and the move is bishop takes d6 and at
first this looks like a mistake
because of what ding played in the game
uh in between move d takes e3
counter-attacking the knight and now
white has
both pieces hanging it looks like
white's in trouble here
but i'm almost positive that magnus had
prepared this position beforehand
uh if we look at the time here and ding
has already used uh close to four
minutes off his clock
and magnus has has more time than he
started with
i believe the the game was 15 plus 10 so
magnus is clearly still in prep and he
blitzed out the move
bishop to a3 so allowing black to take
the knight
and after queen takes d2 a position
arises
where white's down upon but white has
the only dark square bishop
placed on a really really nice diagonal
and the bishop is preventing
black from castling of course it's it's
imbalanced
and it's a question of whether white has
compensation
but i think what ended up happening in
this game
proves that this position is actually
pretty difficult for black to play
and it's not so easy to solve this
castling problem
and meanwhile the king is in the center
with white having two bishops
and a lot of potential to have really
nice piece activity
so going forward from here ding played
knight c6
and it's very likely this move was
played intending to
play 97 to castle and if black gets
just these two moves in then black
should be able to consolidate
and uh probably just have a better
position
so from here magnus strzok immediately
played the very adventurous queen g5
which simply attacks the pawn and it
creates a situation where if black
of course black wants to defend the pawn
but whatever black plays to defend the
pawn
black has to make some concession and
really the two
moves to defend are either g6 or rook g8
now g6 which was not played in the game
is just terribly weakening
whenever there's so many pawns on light
squares
the dark squares are obviously weak and
the queen and bishop
team up very nice h6 is a gaping hole
the queen is tied down to the knight the
king still can't castle
and this would be very very pleasant for
white so
ding played rook g8 in the game which uh
avoids weakening the dark squares but of
course gives up
a kingside casting rights and makes it
so the king
is either stuck in the center or will
have to castle queenside
now from here madness completed
development bishop d3
h6 was played queen retreated queen b6
and this is a really important moment
because maybe a lot of beginners here
would be inclined to take and damage
black's pawn structure
but of course white is down the pawn so
you don't want to be trading without any
good reason
and more importantly white's king just
has
a very safe place while black's king
will be much more exploitable
so with all that in mind it makes sense
for white to
avoid the queen trade magnus played
queen e2 here
after bishop d7 castling
ding decided to castle queenside
and we reached this position where it
seems like
black has actually solved most of the
problems
still has a very nice two center pawns
is up upon
everything's defended in black's
position but it was from here where
magnus
played some some really kind of
brilliant moves
and found a really nice kind of flowing
plan
and uh upon reviewing this game i was
actually really impressed
with magnus's next move and it's a type
of move i don't think i would
consider myself so i'd like to give
viewers a chance to try and
find this move now this is not a tactic
it's just white to move and try and come
up with a plan
you're down upon how can you stir up
some
some ideas some initiative and try and
cause problems for black
okay so before i show what magnus played
i just want to talk about a few key
observations in the position
first of all there is one very key
center square
that white would like to control which
is e5 this is a very typical
of weak square in the london where white
has
good potential to together knight to e5
and further pressure lacks position
another weak point in black's position
is this f7 pawn
which currently has no defenders and
it's not easy for black to
add a defender because the bishop
controls f8 so there's no rook f8
and if we start imagining that we get a
knight to e5
so it can attack f7 that would be the
best way to exert pressure on black's
position
now unfortunately if we play 95 right
away this isn't so effective
black can just take and white's not
really achieving so much
with this trait so the main idea here
is to try and force the knight away from
c6 so we can get in
knight e5 and the move to play is pawn
to b4 so congratulations to
to anyone who found this move maybe
special congratulations to magnus
carlson
for uh for finding the really strong
idea
uh simply wants to play b5 and then
chase away this knight so white's knight
can enter e5
safely so it seems natural for black
to try a6 to prevent b5
but this only makes b5 stronger and
white can still
play this and after the trailer pawns
the b
file is now half open for white rook b1
will come
and this is just really really pleasant
for white
so in the game ding tried king to b8
uh just trying to to get the king to a
slightly safer square
now carlson continues pawn b5
knight a5 and now knight e5 and we're
beginning to see
white form a really nice grip on the
position
attacking f7 sadly for black there's
only one way
to defend f7 which is bishop e8
really sad square for the bishop this
disconnects or rooks
and going forward from here black's
pieces were really just stuck
magnus played bishop to b4 and if we
just glance at black cell up
this knight is completely stuck on a5
the bishop is tied down to the pawn
this rook is stuck on the kings side the
queen is stuck defending the knight
this knight doesn't seem to have any
special squares
so even though white's still down the
pawn this is some very very nice
positional compensation
if we look at white's piece harmony
everything has
kind of a nice home of course the rooks
can be improved
but right now white is just dominating
most most of the key square is in the
position so here dean played
rook to c8 uh white played a4
just reinforcing this this b5 pawn
now the bishop is even more sat on on e8
bishops do not like to stare
at pawn chains like this and now ding
kind of panicked
and played knight e4 and i don't think
you can blame him for this move
because i mean what else to do if if you
look at the engine here the engine will
suggest this very sad move queen d8
which just doesn't seem to have a
purpose and
in positions where your pieces are just
stuck i think it's much
much easier to to make mistakes
now knight e4 was just kind of
self-destructive
the idea was to play f6 but of course
this gives white
a pawn after takes takes takes
and after f6 it looks like black is
getting some initiative looks like the
bishop might free
i'm sure ding was fantasizing about
improving his pieces
but carlson really just didn't give him
any time
and rather than moving the knight away
from e5
magnus found a really really nice
counter attack went for queen
h7 basically trapping the rook
if we notice the rook really doesn't
have any squares
f8 is covered by the bishop and black
would like to
somehow connect the rooks by moving this
bishop
but this bishop really doesn't have any
squares can't move to d7 can't move to
c6
if it moves to h5 knight g7 is just a
fork
winning the queen so
at this point it's already winning for
for white
ding tried one kind of last ditch effort
went for knight b3 uh counter-attacking
the rook
but after queen dig's g8 knight takes a1
uh the icing on the cake magnus played
one more move
which is kind of a queen sacrifice but
not really
the queen takes e8 simply removing the
bishop from defending e7
with idea after rook e8 knight g7 will
win the queen
and then white will pick up the knight
and the end
and have an easily winning end game so
ding resigned after queen takes e8 it is
true that maybe black could try
taking the knight here but after a move
like queen h5
the knight is still hanging this pawn is
now hanging
assuming the knight moves white can take
with check and pick up this pawn
and it's a pretty easy win for white
going forward from here so
i really enjoyed this game not only
because it featured a new idea
which i've never seen before in the
london opening but
featured some really really nice kind of
positional play where white was down
upon early
but found some nice nice compensation
and goes to show that material isn't
everything
it was really a brilliant game on
magnus's parts
and i think this goes to show why the
london opening
can still live on there can still be new
innovations
even from very early on i mean the
novelty in this game
was move seven which is uh which is
pretty mind-blowing
so i really hope you guys enjoyed that
uh speaking of the london
i do plan to upload my london themed
match
against levy rosman also known as gotham
chess
that will probably be my next upload um
i usually upload at 7am central time
and i don't want to spoil the result of
that match but we had some really cool
games
a lot of fun a lot of fun kind of
variety of lines in the london opening
so stay tuned for that and also
speaking of gotham chess i'll be joining
him tomorrow
on his channel it will also be on
hikaru's twitch channel
we'll be doing commentary of day two of
the magnus carlson
invitational finals where we'll see many
more games
uh between these players so mark your
calendars for august 10th
um probably probably about 12 hours
after the the post of this video so with
that
i really hope you guys have a good day
or
a good night or a good bishop